shop frontage to potentially look at
alleviating this problem this is not
something that would be affordable and
compulsory purchase of land is a long
complex and costly process
which the council and tfgm
could would not be looking to pursue as
part of the active travel agenda
improving pedestrian and alternative
travel options across the borough is now
a key priority across gm and therefore
any potential redesign would have to
look at also improving sighting and
pedestrian movement
reducing the area for movement of
pedestrians at this junction would
reduce the current pedestrian capacity
in location that is especially well used
by pedestrians
tfgm have however been asked to look at
the traffic signal timings and traffic
flows at this junction to see if any
changes can be made that will assist
in improving the movement of traffic
through the junction thank you
councillor boys do you have a
supplementary question yes thank you um
this is amended actually thank you
councillor i said for your response and
your confirmation that effectively the
the solution that we all would know
would work is actually not affordable um
given that the congestion directly
impacts upon wards with sitting
counsellors from all four parties
represented here tonight can we have an
assurance that as you speak in terms of
the investigations going on from the
phasing of the lights that this takes
place in an expedite manner and perhaps
we could have a report back on on that
say
no later than perhaps the let's have a
think it would be the october council
meeting thank you
counselor i said
thank you mayor thank you council board
for your supplementary
obviously i think we're quite happy to
provide you information in one form
about another i don't know whether a
report can be brought to council because
i don't know whether it's that sort of
format but certainly we can get the
information that is helpful
i think one of the further information
i've had actually as well which really
complicates this matter is that there is
a significant
number of utilities actually under that
footwear around there which actually
make it extremely difficult in addition
to the problems that previously
mentioned in that as well obviously
quite happy to work with yourselves and
see what can be done with this but
obviously i'll speak with officers about
this and we'll actually uh see
when we can get you some information on
this but obviously uh we are working
with tsm as well so we need to actually
make sure we get the information as soon
as possible i don't know when that will
be but we'll as soon as it's available
and sure we we get that to you
thank you
thank you councillor ad said question
for councillor morgan your question
please
thank you
thank you mayor um in the 1718 financial
year the last year trafford was under a
conservative administration trafford nbc
was 16th in the national recycling
league tables according to let's
recycle.com could the executive member
for environment and regulatory services
please give the latest publicly
available position in those league
tables thank you
morgan for your question
the latest available data
is from 2020 2021 and half was 53rd out
of 338 local authorities in the league
table it is worth noting that in 2021
pandemic
and work from home mandate saw this
amount of types of waste that we collect
change significantly the amount of waste
we collected for recycling from
households in 2021
increased however the amount of
non-recyclable waste increased more than
the waste for recycling in early 2020 we
also continued to see a significant
reject rate for paper and cardboard
while significant campaign reduced the
amount of contamination later in the
year overall in england the official
waste from households recycling was 44
in 2020 down 1.5 and 45.5
in 2019 traffic is still significantly
higher than the average recycling rate
at 53.3 percent thank you
thank you councillor rad said councillor
morgan do you have a supplementary
question i do thank you matt um the um
thank to the executive member for his
response um and he stated himself that
falling to 53rd is a direct reflection
of the fallen recycling rate to 59 to 53
percent um can he confirm the total cost
of increased charges traffic has had to
pay due to the six percent drop in
recycling rates
council right said
uh thank you
thank you councillor morgan for
supplementary i'd have to get those
figures because obviously i've got them
with me now so uh if you lays with me
afterwards i'm sure we get you those
figures there but i would also add as
well on doing so uh
information relating as you will be
aware part of the significant change in
the downturn was due to the conservative
green bin tax which actually had a
severe impact on the amount that was
being recycled during those year and it
was obviously
after these green bin tax was actually
scrapped the figures were expected to
start coming up and there was some
evidence of that unfortunately then
covered here and that affected the whole
thing and a lot of information related
is actually on the death row website as
well don't forget the figures nationally
thank you councillor ad said question
five councillor holden for the next
question please comment thank you
a little heavy on numbers this evening
in a recent press release celebrating
the secondary school offer day
the council confirmed the offering of
one of their three preferences
to 91 of trafford's children
could the lead member of education tell
us how many of these young people were
offered a place at their first
preference school
thank you councillor holden councillor
carter as lead member for education
would like to respond to this question
please and before you do councillor
carter can i say i'm very happy to see
you here this evening
after your recent uh
[Applause]
i was going to bamboozle council holding
with a load of figures but you know
let's take it
so
of the 3
340 on-time applications received
2542 children were allocated their first
preference so that's 76
however
we have a lot of ineligible applications
in trafford
we have this year it was nearly 400 and
these are families who put grammar
schools down and then the child doesn't
pass the entrance exam
so
how we work out is if you've applied for
one grammar school and you don't get in
but you get your first high school that
is counted as first preference
so families that applied for three
grammar schools and got the first high
school would come up in my data as
fourth preference but it's actually
their first preference
if you add all that together it's 82
and i did uh check the national average
which is 81.1 percent so we're fairly
bob on on trafford so thank you
thank you councillor carter councillor
holden do you have a supplementary
question i do mr mayor
the numbers are impressive
as is our education system
however there are pockets
especially
mary's pocket
where
a great deal
is made of my year
doing appeals
for parents whose children are sent to
schools
outside their community often
considerably outside their community
i wonder if
you could share the plan
that you have
to actually maintain that community
cohesion
by increasing the
possibility
of children going on to secondary school
with their friends and colleagues from
their primary school
thank you
yeah thank you um
there will be a plan i haven't got that
plan with me today but i do share your
concerns
i think if we
obviously as a borough we can't up we
can advocate for more schools but it's
the dfe that decide whether we get them
and on paper if i worked in whitehall
and i didn't know trafford it would look
like we had enough school places
but i think the issue is for you and for
myself and for lots of members in the
chamber they're not in the right way you
know where we're getting pressure from
members
now we go to the dfe and we tell them
this and they go yeah but you've got
loads of places
so that's the dilemma so they're
obviously there is a school place board
um i haven't got a hotline to nadine
zahawi maybe you have um
but
but um you know i absolutely do accept
that we have pressure
certainly in the sale area and also the
altering area as well
um
but
you know it that's out of our hands but
obviously i can go back to school places
board and ask if they've got a plan
but we do ask a lot you know like we ask
regularly we're not asking a lot from
them we're asking for a new school
so
you councillor carter
question six councillor miss blackburn
please can you now put the last of this
evening's questions okay thank you mayor
um would the exec member inform me why
money is being spent on white's road
markings being repainted whilst there
are hundreds of pots holes that require
filling
council said would you like to respond
thank you
thank you council blackburn for your
question
as highway authority trafford have a
static duty to maintain
all of the highway asset
other than just the road surface and
this includes road markings
road markings provide road users with
guidance on how to use the road and is
important contributing factor for
improving road safety particularly at
junctions
white line replacement is often
undertaken in large areas or on entire
votes as the major
cost is in the mobilization of the
equipment relative cost of replacing
white lines is small in comparison to
repair or potholes
included in replacement markings is lane
demarcations left and right turns give
way and stop lines which if we're faded
beyond recognition and there was a
subsequent accident the council could be
liable for any claim therefore highway
maintenance budgets are spent on a
number of different repairs including
potholes signage and vote markings to
keep the road users safe when using the
roads thank you
thank you councillor i'd said councillor
miss blackburn do you have a
supplementary question
yes i do
um could i ask the executive member um
how much this council has paid out in
compensation to road users for damage
caused to their vehicles coming into
contact with potholes during the
municipal year
council right said
thank you mayor thank you councillor
blackburn for your supplementary uh
obviously i don't have that information
with me because obviously i wasn't
aware that i'm gonna ask that but
however if you lay with me after the
meeting i'm sure you get answers that i
have seen the information previously and
it
is catalogued there so we can get that
information with you basically
afterwards i'll ensure that information
is given to you thank you
thank you councillor i'd said
item 4 is a report concerning the
high-speed rail
and i am advised that councillor wright
executive member for housing and
regeneration is to introduce and move
the report councillor wright please
thank you chair
you will note from the report that the
time scales involved for us to petition
the government and hs2 and the potential
impacts of the construction and running
of the project are extremely tight
members will be aware that we are
currently drafting our response to the
environmental statements which will form
form the basis for our petitioning of
government on which this report is based
given the time scales involved and the
importance of the council seeking
mitigations from government
around the construction delivery and
running of hs2 this report seeks
approval for the council to project to
elements of the 82 phase 2b bill based
on the framework set out in the report
the in-depth detail of which will of
course be shared with members as time
goes on and work on the petition
continues
there will of course be opportunities
for members to contribute to this work
as they have been during the last few
weeks where we have received
contributions regarding the
environmental statements i'll move the
report thank you chair
thank you councillor wright is the
report seconded the secondary chair and
reserved the right to speak thank you
thank you councillor weston any members
wishing to speak
councillor welton please
thank you man um this uh report is a
real wake-up call regarding the huge
implications the construction of hs2
will have for local residents and our
environment
uh the green group has submitted a
response to the council that has the
implications for local people and our
climate emergency response at its heart
and we're really pleased to see many of
our concerns echoed in this report
as it stands construction could make
meeting our climate emergency targets
much harder
much more needs to be done to offset the
embodied emissions involved with the
construction not just the operation of
the line
and in particular we think the airport
station should be reviewed as a real
opportunity to install a substantial
solar pv scheme um that commit against
mitigate against the embodied in
emissions from construction and
maintenance over time
we welcome the demand for a much more
detailed plan for ecological mitigation
and biodiversity net gain a huge project
like this project like this will put our
ecosystems under huge strain and that
impact needs to be properly understood
before construction begins so that it
can be compensated for while building
work is in progress
most stark are the implications for the
communities around the construction
sites and we owe it to those communities
to ensure everything possible is done to
prepare for the increase in traffic
before it arrives
road safety has to be prioritized
requiring travel plans that minimize and
mitigate hgv and lgb trips and the
development of comprehensive cycling and
walking networks ensuring that our
communities remain collected and are not
severed from each other while works goes
work goes on and once the line is in
operation
but we finally we recognize that
responding to this bill is is a huge
undertaking and the green group would
like to thank all involved for their
efforts on behalf of residents we hope
and expect that there will be
significant improvements to the bill as
a result
thank you
thank you councillor welton councillor
evans like to speak
thank you thank you chair um i welcome
the report um
there are clearly
this needs to be ongoing um
and and the the time scales that we've
had i've i made my comments uh last in
my probably exec about the flooding
issues are going to come in in simply
brooklyn and broadhead following the
installation you know the train station
and things like the goldberg link we
still need to be objecting to that i've
been notified this week about problems
along the bowling about the dumping of
the waste of the spoil that comes up
which is going to cause problems to
residents so we need this needs to be
just ongoing and i would i would hope
and that yes we'll submit this report
but we probably need a whole department
to handle it is so big and then finally
the concept of moving the station from
where it's being placed nearer the
airport hopefully to do away with the
need to actually put a rail link in
between the new station and the airport
there are many things could be done and
i think perhaps we do need to set up a
department i know it's a cost but
actually i think there's so much to be
spoken about but for the moment thank
you for the work that's gone into this
report in such a short length of time
thank you councillor evans any other
members wishing to speak
anybody
else counselor bots
yeah i just wanted to express my
concerns as well i think they will have
been incorporated regarding the
closeness of
my ward near to the state proposed
station
on hill road there that the
operations are going to be such they're
not going to
cause so much
traffic uh congestion in that area thank
you
thank you council councillor new grosh
thank you um the i would like to echo
everything that's been said in response
there um both praise and concern uh i
would also echo the fact that there is a
possibility of having manchester airport
station on the east the manchester
airport side of the motorway which would
be far more environmentally sustainable
than placing it on greenfield and
greenbelt
it would also limit the damage to
ancient woodland that's at that location
so thank you that's our comments cheers
thank you councillor new grosh any other
members wishing to speak
no okay
um the report has been moved and
seconded can it be agreed
thank you
item six is the code of council a code
of conduct which has been recommended by
the executive and again
apologies everybody we're going to item
five
it's a paid policy statement
for
2022-23 referred from employment
committee and i invite councillor ross
the executive member for finance and
governance to introduce and move the
report councillor ross please
thank you mayor this is a standard
report we bring to council each year
which sets out the council's approach to
pay policy in accordance with the
requirements of section 38 of the
localism localism act 2011
so i'm sure you're familiar with the
format the purpose of the pay policy
statement is to ensure transparency and
accountability with regard to the
council's approach to setting pay and
i'll just pull out a couple of key
highlights from the report
included in the report are our pay
ratios we monitor these these to
understand how the salary of our most
senior officers compare with our lowest
paid staff and the average employee this
year we can see that the ratio of pay of
our chief executive and that of our
median earner is 6.92
to 1. this has stayed the same as last
year
the ratio between the lowest paid
employee and average chief officer is
5.55 to 1. the ratio has reduced from
last year when it was 5.76 to 1 and this
is a positive change
also included in our report is the
gender pay gap
every year we work out our gender pay
gap figures and report them and consider
the reasons for our gap and what we must
do to move the dial
the figures we will report in the
national system at the end of march and
are based on payroll data from march
2021 as there is always a one-year lag
traffic council's overall mean paid gap
is 8.14
and the median is 10.77
both in favor of male employees
there are a number of influencing
factors which combine to give our gap
and i'll just mention these briefly
our gender pay gap is significantly
affected by the gender composition of
our workforce which is 76 female and 24
male
we employ a lot of part-time roles in
trafford 49 of posts which attract women
and evidence shows that part-time roles
pay less than full-time roles
when part-time roles are looked at the
gender pay gap is more positive for
women for full-time employees the gender
pay gap is lower than the whole
workforce 1.47 percent mean and 8.59
median
we have some large in-house services
with lower paid bands which
traditionally attract more women
catering cleaning pasture assistance
care assistants and support workers if
we remove these groups the gaps would
reduce
last year we had a pay gap of 9.75 and a
median pay gap of 15.46
so both figures have reduced and
particularly the medium by 30 percent
the figures have reduced since we
started reporting the uh in 2017 and
this is obviously a positive move with
some way to go
we'll continue to explore reasons for
our gender pay gap to consider what
measures we can put in place with the
aim of reducing it further
the pay gap in organizations can be very
much due to the type of workforce of
roles employed the gaps across different
local authorities will vary a lot
dependent on how each service has
included in-house and sub-contracted
services
we'll continue to work towards reducing
this gap however due to the makeup of
our workforce the reality is that we'll
be unlikely to get
to the point of having no gap unless
it's a huge societal shift in terms of
the types of role men and women
undertake
the pay policy for 2223 has therefore
been recommended by employment committee
for approval here at council thank you
matt
thank you councillor ross is the report
second policy statement seconded please
seconded chairman was that the right
thanks thank you councillor weston any
members wishing to speak
councillor myers please
thank you mayor and thank you for that
report councillor ross
uh it's
obviously very welcome that that gender
that the gender pay gap is closing but
can i ask is it in any way comparable to
other councils in greater manchester
thank you councillor miles i think
that's a really good question i don't
have the answer here but i'll ensure
that we all get that answer because we
need to learn from what other
authorities are doing if they're doing
something differently and indeed
something that we can improve on further
thank you councillor ross anybody else
wish to comment
no okay the report has been moved
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed please all right thank
you
96 code of conduct is the council code
of conduct which has been recommended by
the executive and again i asked
councillor ross executive member for
finance and governance to introduce the
report
and move the recommendations please
counselor ross
thank you mayor
members will have seen the revised code
of conduct under agenda item six
it has been to standards committee it
has also been to the scrutiny committee
on the 7th of february 2022 and in
accordance with the constitution we're
recommending it to be adopted by the
council this evening thank you thank you
councillor ross is that seconded please
second hidden reserve chair thanks thank
you councillor weston any members
wishing to speak
no
okay
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed please
all right thank you
item seven contract procedure rules
is a report of the executive member for
finance and governance on the contract
procedure rules which has been
recommended by the executive and i now
ask councillor ross to re to introduce
and move the report recommendations
please counselor ross
thank you mayor i'm sure all members
have read the report in full um i'd like
to assure members that it has been on a
long journey in the space of a few weeks
and obviously a lot of work has been
going on behind the scenes with
trafford's legal team in the lead
consulting with our star procurement
legal teams in
stockport rochdale and thameside the key
amendments are data detailed in the
report and in the summary and afford
some of operational relief without any
significant changes to the robustness of
the original governance framework
this report has been through as i say a
series of stages and in line with the
constitution the standards committee and
scrutiny committee approved and proposed
the construct procedure rules and
recommend them for adoption by the
council thank you
thank you councillor ross is that
seconded please second lecture
thank you
any members wishing to speak
no okay
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed please
thank you
item eight
please would councillor ross also like
to introduce and move the next item
concerning a review of the council's
scrutiny arrangements councillor ross
please
thank you mayor um
obviously it would have been appropriate
for councillor david acting as the chair
of scrutiny to um to introduce this
report to council this evening but i'm
doing it in my role as exec member for
finance and governance um
your members will see the reports before
them and they'll also see there's a
number of recommendations for
improvements set out in section six of
the report um i have to say i welcome
the improvements that are set out i
think it will make for a better scrutiny
i had the pleasure of joining scrutiny
uh last wednesday and i have to say the
um the the caliber of the questions um
on show from from members that lead me
to to to to think that you know that
it's scrutiny is is healthy as the the
reporter cited and you know people are
not afraid to take people to task which
is absolutely how it should be whether
it be the executive or whether it be
agencies who operate in trafford so i am
happy to move the recommendations as set
out in the report
thank you councillor ross is the report
seconded
seconded chair i i think i just
reflect as councillor ross did on the
findings in the report that we do have a
solid base but there are some
recommendations in there for us to take
forward and just to commit on behalf of
the executive
that we will look to engage as fully as
possible
in the scrutiny process as we always
have but also
with any um changes that come about as a
result the recommendations thank you
chair
thank you councillor western do any
members wish to speak on this report
council accordingly please
thank you chip
um i really welcome this report i i i've
served on a number of scrutinies in my
time um
i've got to say since 2007
scrutiny has has deteriorated almost on
a straight line in that time through
both
um conservative rule and labour rule
i think
a lot of it's down to the resources that
are given to um scrutiny um back in 2007
there was a lot more staff and there
were a lot more support for the various
scrutiny committees and we did good work
there's still good work going on and i
really welcome this report um
it's come up with some really good um
suggestions and i don't want i the one
of the reasons i wanted to speak is that
i don't want them to be sort of packaged
up and forgotten about they're calling
for large support for pre-decision
scrutiny we have been calling that for
10 years at least pre-decision scrutiny
and i i think you know if we're agreeing
this then it needs to be absolutely
explicit that we're going to use
pre-decision scrutiny because i think
that would be a game changer have clear
mechanisms for monitoring actions and
achievements so it's not just patted on
the back and and said thank you very
much scrutiny you've got lots of good
ideas see you book bye bye and and and
to be
i'm i'm not being part of political that
has been it through both parties a lot
to influence rather than just asking for
information too often
it is about a powerpoint presentation
and we've had too much depth by
powerpoint have more scrutiny with
focused committees able to challenge
executive decisions that's in there
that's in the report and i think it's
good stuff so yeah the suggestions go on
and on and really powerful and positive
and then you've got the um uh the the
the the
the governing and scrutiny consultancy
and and they've made some steel ones and
and and and i think they make the point
that it's got to be the executive member
takes a much more stronger lead and not
just officers that come and i think that
is vitally important more emphasis on
scrutiny is a vital part of council
business and i really believe that um i
haven't got any more skin in the game
but i do hope you take this one
seriously because actually um how it was
presented to executive on monday was we
there's lots of good stuff in there
we'll accept it i think we as the
council body need to hold this to
account it's not the executive holding
scrutiny to greg count it's the other
way round and i think we've got to be a
lot stronger on that
um
so yeah no i fully support the work
that's gone on here but i do hope you
take it seriously
thank you very much
thank you council accordingly councillor
welcome please
thank you very much and uh thank you
council accordingly for all your work
all
through the years on the many scrutiny
groups that you've you've been on and
for those words and i do hope that we'll
we will hold
uh
we will hold the executive to that as
you as you say i know councillor jerome
has been very um very involved in this
and if he didn't have covert tonight he
would be been very pleased to have
spoken
on it um we have been pleased to have
been involved in the review and we would
like to thank the members of the
scrutiny review panel and the staff at
the center or for governance and
scrutiny for their work we welcome the
recommendations which will enable a
group of our size to better participate
despite the formal requirements of
proportionality
and residents do deserve effective
scrutiny but it can only be as good as
the members that participate so the
commitment to additional training and
briefing is is very welcome
um it also requires the offices and
departments have the capacity as council
accordingly says to respond to scrutiny
requests this is not always the case and
as we have found in the recent failed
attempt to establish
the pothole scrutiny group which never
somehow happened and hopefully that will
happen again
after the elections in may
we do particularly welcome the proposals
for closer interaction between the
executive and the scrutiny committee and
we hope that that will lead to the work
of the committee being more directly
relevant to the administration's agenda
and will thus directly feed into policy
making thank you
thank you councillor welton councillor
dagnall please
hi just a just a quick word as somebody
who sat on the scrutiny review um group
it was an absolute pleasure to to work
alongside uh the rest of the members on
that review group led very capably by by
councillor acton who can't be here
tonight i just wanted to say that there
was a great deal of consensus reached
i'm really pleased to say that actually
the the group of members who were there
anticipated very many of the
recommendations made by the center for
governance and scrutiny which just goes
to show what enthusiasm and interest
that members have for scrutiny and i
would also just like to take this
opportunity to thank john addison and
alex murray and fabiola when she was
with us for the great support that they
gave us they were extremely attentive
they provided lots of opportunities to
meet they were very tolerant of a lot of
enthusiastic ideas being thrown about um
and they were very um responsive in
providing reports and taking minutes for
us so just to say thank you to everybody
who did offer us that support and the i
think i speak for all of us on the
screen review group when i say that we
are really pleased with the outcome of
this and would all like to take the
opportunity to move it forward in the
future so if it's anything to do with us
we will absolutely make sure that it
happens thank you
thank you councillor dagnall councillor
oxford please
yeah i just want to echo what everybody
everybody else has said it was a great
privilege to take part in this and i
feel really excited about how it all
moved forward it hopefully be a lot
tighter and i'm also
really interested in engaging more of
the community in scrutiny as well thank
you
thank you councillor oxford anybody else
wish to comment councillor but
it's just to say that i think uh
councillor cordon has reflected it
admirably in terms of what the scrutiny
function does and that just
emphasizes the fact that we need this
kind of scrutiny at the gmca level which
is
clearly missing thank you
thank you council about anybody else
okay the report has been moved and
seconded can it be agreed please
thank you
item nine and the council is requested
to agree the provisional calendar of
council and committee meetings for 2022
2023
would the leader of the council move
this item
so moved thank you
is that seconded
yes seconded thank you mr man thank you
councillor heinz
can i ask if the council is in agreement
or do any members wish to speak
okay can we agree that
thank you
item 10
this evening four motions have been
listed on the summons in the order they
were received
may i remind members that to get through
the business and to give everyone who
wants to an opportunity to speak
it may be necessary to limit the time
for speeches
therefore please can everyone keep their
comments concise and to the point and to
avoid repetition deviation
i forgot the other one
hesitation hesitation
of points already been made thank you
you will be aware from the summons that
the first two motions concern ukraine
and since it is anticipated that the
debates and comments will be similar for
both i am proposing that we consider
them together
i will ask that in turn each is moved
and seconded and then i will invite
members to speak before determining each
separately
furthermore i understand the proposed
amendment to the conservative motion is
to be accepted
therefore on this basis the mirror of
the motion will signify an old
alteration to reflect the amendment and
the council will be asked to consent
proceeding with then the first motion
regarding the russian action in ukraine
i have received notice that this is to
be moved by councillor morgan councillor
morgan please
um
thank you very much mr bear um i'm
incredibly sad that we happen to propose
this motion tonight and i'm sure the
proposed the labor motion um following
it would stay the same
i know i speak of every councillor in
this chamber tonight that we are
horrified by what's happening in ukraine
whilst we've seen awful crimes in europe
since the second world war whether it be
the soviet crushing of the uprisings in
budapest or prague and the wars in the
form yugoslavia in the late 1990s the
speed and brutality of what russian
forces are doing in ukraine is truly
horrendous
we've seen the city of america flattened
whilst russian troops tried to starve it
into submission and it seemed
reminiscent of the worst scenes of the
end of the second world war
a european capital is again under siege
with families shot as they're trying to
get food
in occupied kirsten this week ukrainian
protest has been shot at and murdered by
russian troops
we've seen local mayors arrested and
sent for show trials in russia
for serving the nation that they swore
an oath to we've seen the disappearance
of minorities including the crimean
tatar community who have suffered so
greatly over the recent centuries
and like in every war in history stories
of violence and rape on women and girls
and this week ukrainian civilians
abducted in buses to be sent to work
camps in the centre of russia
all in total breach of the very basics
of the warfare we've
set ourselves
but let's remember the signs there that
were there before
even before he became president as prime
minister putin led the invasion of
chechnya and gave russian forces the
green light to flatten the city of
grozny with an estimated 80 000 dead
followed by an illegal invasion of
georgia the illegal annexation of crimea
the propping up of the butcher of
damascus bashar al-assad devastating
aleppo idlib and other syrian cities his
assassinated opponents not just in
russia on the streets of britain
and what have we done for those crimes
we've welcomed him worked with him
tolerated him hillary clinton in 2008
just after the invasion of georgia had a
photo op with a big reset button with
lavrov
putin has seen the west move on after
he's done one outrageous crime after
another and we cannot go back
with him or other dictators
we've categorically stated the
importance of not allowing aggression to
redraw international boundaries and for
good reason
but there's a long list of so-called
people's republics
with russian troops stationed in them
whether in georgia in the donbass or
transgenistria in moldova all i'm sure
with disgraceful examples of referendums
which were about as free as those
imposed by the nazi regime in the 1930s
and where does this stop mr mayor
there are russian huge russian
communities in
baltic states in central asia which are
relatively well integrated
and that's why i'm um
mr mayor we we need to support our nato
allies and it's so important and can i
put on record and how pleased i am to
see kia stammer visiting our troops in
estonia last week um president biden has
referred to putin as a bloodthirsty war
criminal and that is what he is
uh putin lavrov shogu and the other war
criminals in the russian regime need to
be on trial
but let's be clear this is putin's war
not the war of the russian people
they are going to suffer and even die
because of what we're we're having to do
as um as a country and as the west
but this is what is happening putin's
choice
even today there were reports of the
lack of tense for the russian troops and
conditions being so bad they're getting
frostbite
this war is putin's
mayor 13 months ago 30 months ago for my
mini-moon um we visited kiev
it's an absolutely amazing city um
and ukraine is a fantastic country we
actually went on ukrainian independence
day weekend which coincides with the
orcs bank holiday weekend
and um
we actually heard president zielinski
speak admittedly across a very huge
crowd and he was speaking in ukrainian
which i can't say i
understand a word of
but it's a truly international city with
people from around the world
given the damage putin's troops are do
inflicting on the city in the wider
country and it will take a lot of time
to recover but i hope an independent
free ukraine gets the full support of
the west to rebuild
and having met the ukrainian people and
seen the resolve they have for fighting
for their liberty over the last month
and i'm sure they will and they hope
members of this chamber can one day
visit and give their support to the
courageous ukrainian people
um on the labour amendment as we said
we'll be supporting it um we um in this
chamber have to have a united voice
tonight in support of the ukrainian
people both here in trafford and back in
ukraine fighting with with their lives
for freedom liberty and independence
um finally mr um
in honor of the proud and heroic
ukrainian people whether they be
ukrainian speakers or russian speakers
in their time of need slava ukraine
thank you councillor morgan is the
motion seconded
second he'd miss mayor and i'll speak to
it now for me bear with me councillor
evans
thank you mayor
councillor morgan are you happy to
accept the alteration
thank you council evans you're very
welcome to second
thank you uh again mayor and this time
last week i found myself at a train
station 20 miles uh inside poland from
the ukraine border
and it was quite easy i bought a ticket
i got a train i went to krakow i bought
another ticket i got an easy jet i was
home i was in bed by one o'clock i was
in the
imperial hotel
in blackpool the friday night with
friends
while i was at that station a family of
six
turned up
that was it they have nowhere to go
just had what they had with them can you
imagine tomorrow tell you tonight pack
one bag you're leaving tomorrow
nowhere to go
so i can't really
more than that speak to this motion so i
thought i'd read a blog
of a and whether this is translated
correctly and that is the
sucker cover
which has been written
and this was written on the 19th of
march in maripole
uh excuse the translation but it is what
it is i go out on the street during
breaks between bombs
i need to walk the dog she is constantly
sneezing shaking and hiding behind my
feet
i always want to sleep
my yard surrounded by many stories is
quiet and dead
i am no longer afraid to look around
opposite the entrance
is a block
the flame devoured five floors and
slowly chews through the six
the fire in the room burns neatly like a
fireplace
black tiled windows stand without glass
from them like tongs curtains fall out
of them
i look at this calmly and cursed
i'm sure i'm going to die soon
that's a matter of days
in this city everyone is constantly
waiting for death
i just wish she wasn't so scary
three days ago a friend of my oldest
nephew visited us and told us that it
was a direct hit into the fire
department the rescuers have lost their
lives
one woman's hand leg and head tore off
i dream of my body parts staying still
even after an air bomb blast
i don't know why but i think this is
important
although on the other hand there will
still be no burial during combat
this is how the police respond to us
when we caught them on the street and
asked what to do with our friend's dead
grandmother
they advise us to put it on the balcony
i wonder how many balconies our dead
bodies lying on
our house on mera avenue is the only one
without direct hits
he was hit by shells twice glass flew
out in some apartments but he was hardly
injured and looks lucky compared to the
other houses
the whole yard is covered with a few
layers of ash glass plastic and metal
shards
me trying not to look at the iron full
flying in the playground i think it's a
rocket or maybe it's gone i don't care
it's just uncomfortable in the third
floor window i see someone's face and
it's chasing me
turns out i'm afraid of living people
my dog is starting to howl and i
understand they are going to shoot again
now i am standing outside during the day
and there's a cemetery silence around me
there are no cars no voices no children
no grandmothers on benches even the wind
is dead
a few people on here though they are
lying on the side of the house and in
the parking lot covered with cloths i
don't want to look at them i'm afraid
i'll see someone i know
all life in my city is now mumbling in
the basements she looks like a candle in
the wind there's nothing to put her out
any vibration or wind and darkness will
come i try to cry but i can't i feel
sorry for myself my family my husband my
neighbours my friends i go back to the
basement
it's been two weeks and i can't believe
there was
once another life people continue to sit
in the basement in maripo every day it's
harder for them to survive they have no
water no food light they can't even go
outside because of constant shelling
mariopol residents must live help them
out tell about it let everyone know that
the killing of peaceful people cannot
continue that was written on the 19th of
march at nine o'clock we're now on what
the 23rd thankfully that person posted
again 12 hours ago
we've got to support this motion mr
mayor thank you
thank you councillor evans
i now call for the second motion
considering the situation in ukraine to
be removed
to be moved councillor dr carr please
thank you chair
i'm sure i speak on behalf of the whole
chamber in condemning the appalling
violence being directed against ukraine
i think this has been
oddly one of the most difficult speeches
to write because as we've just heard
it is unimaginable
um to think about the horror
that these people must be going through
i can't imagine what it must be like to
leave
my livelihood to not know if my family
are safe
to not be able to look at my children
and tell them whether they'll ever see
their family members again
or whether they're someone that they
know is going to die in the night
we've all watched with horror
while the ukrainian people have suffered
unimaginable terror including inhumane
acts of brutality towards civilians
bombing patients in hospitals and
children in preschools
as well as human rights offences and war
crimes
this war is absolutely abhorrent and i'm
sure that as a council and as a
community we all want to work together
to do everything that we can to support
ukraine and the refugees fleeing the
violence
it's important also to remember that
putin's actions are not on behalf of the
russian people
it's not right or acceptable to
discriminate against russian people
living in trafford and the motion
rightly condemns this
we stand in solidarity with ukraine and
call for an end to this horrific
brutality
thank you councillor dr carr councillor
right we'll second the motion
thank you chair uh most of what i uh
wanted to say has already been said by
other members in the chamber however in
seconding this motion i will simply say
that this is not the time for political
opportunism opportunism this is not the
time for people to use this illegal
invasion of a sovereign nation to
further their agenda this is the time
for us to stand with the people of
ukraine against the barbaric atrocities
being committed by putin
the economic fallout from this invasion
will be felt by the whole world
however the people that matter of the
innocent ukrainians being caught up in
this devastation
and the russian people who come out into
the streets of moscow and other cities
to protest their opposition despite the
very real risk to their safety
it should not be underestimated how
brave an action that is
unless i'm sure i speak for every other
member of in this chamber when i say we
salute this act of bravery and defiance
in spite of putin's threat to their
safety thank you chair
thank you councillor wright
both motions have been moved and
seconded and are before the council for
debate do any members wish to speak to
them counselor welton button please
thank you
i spent a long long time thinking about
what i wanted to say tonight and um
i've got quite a lot to say
it starts with one man what one man in
relative isolation who's taken hold of a
landmass
of continental europe by the lapels
stared into its eyes with his blank
stare and shaking it until it squealed
like a ruffian
kicking off in a pub he has shocked
everyone around him
we have all enjoyed a long period of
european peace most of us have never
known war to be this close to us
this close to home
wars was something that happened a long
way away in lands that looked different
to ours
where maybe life even seemed to some to
mean less
but as a population we don't do wars
yes we do have our forces
they're often kept busy but these days
our real air force has been the budget
airlines
we took euro and europe by storm as
tourists as travelers not as invaders
we take ryanair and easyjet
to all of the european cities for short
breaks
hem parties sometimes and cold beer
but now comparatively out of the blue
europe is adopting a new frame of mind
every european nation is rechecking
their own circumstances
countries we take for granted as safe
and collaborative allies like finland
and sweden
begin to realize that their
long-standing political status could
actually now make them targets
baltic states know that they are likely
to be targets
national leaders everywhere in europe
are reviewing defenses
those that can have all reached for the
nato manual
commentators are not alone in
speculating what happens next
closer to home here in our region
as a multicultural area
an area of universities and a large
airport
greater manchester will have a multitude
of residents
and communities that will be observing
ukraine
and this new order
that's emerging with rare bewilderment
alongside the emotional responses
people here
us
we start living with consequences fuel
costs soaring
from already
highest ever price marks
food costs rising too with more to come
but for us it is all relative because we
can still get fuel we can still get food
we can get water
for millions in ukraine it is a very
different set of circumstances
bleak circumstances
and as it is endured this situation will
change many things for many of us
and those around us
german teenagers we here are suddenly
feeling newly aware
and have become
scared of world events which are
unexpectedly now european events
war for them is less than two hours away
i suspect that many of us will change
some of our habits we will narrow our
scope to travel we will be less the
explorers that we were
as recently as pre-pandemic
normal living will take on a rel a new
element of consideration
considering previously impossible
scenarios as potential scenarios
ukrainian people
and the ways of modern life that they
were adopting
are all in disarray this war has placed
them
in the equivalent of the eye of a
hurricane
if it doesn't blow you away
it will blow away everything that you
possess
plus your hospitals and your schools
can can you imagine that can any of us
imagine that look around
you in your own home
and imagine it wrecked
and there's no one there to help you
you have what you stand up in
in your shock you pick up some dinner
plates that aren't broken
you don't know why
but you know that you have to get away
those tv pictures that we see are
haunting
the shattered apartment blocks that now
stand like tombstones
some of them sadly
are tombs
in the media coverage we hear so much
so much that is horrific it highlights
the modern day scope
of man's inhumanity to man
a young girl still only a child lies
silent in shock
in hospital
because her leg has been blown off
not ten years
not yet 10 years old
and the despot miles away from her has
brought it about that she violently
loses a leg
he sleeps at night while she weeps at
night
little boy of three with shrapnel wounds
in his stomach
plays with a little toy truck in his
hospital cot
these two children
won't yet know that the russians
describe them as actors portraying
wounded people
the capacity of russia for disgusting
propaganda knows no limit
nor depths below
which it will not stoop as it seeks to
mislead its own populace and deceive the
world
a woman a mother describes the
inhumanity and ignominy of passing
through a russian checkpoint
mocked by soldiers
taunted about her destination being the
next target the next target for
bombardment
she carries all she has left in the
world a european woman
a woman who might now be on her way to
the uk
maybe to trafford
an older man formerly a hunter of wild
boar and other animals
now volunteers as a sniper
eager to kill as he put it
the russian animals destroying my
country
the ukrainian people
were relatively happy european nation
until just days ago they were going
places as a country as a nationality
making progress in this modern world to
their pride
and
and to their pride and a major food
producing country
but now they are a mix of bewildered
refugees and stoic freedom fighters
they are led by someone they elected
someone who does lead by consent someone
who is determined to defend his homeland
from this failed modern
modern day angelus
what we have seen in the ukrainian
people what we've seen the ukrainian
people endure is something that would
flatten the spirit of many people
yet they stand they struggle and they
fight
they do all of these things in a manner
that deserves more than admiration more
than financial support it deserves uh
outstretched arms our welcome our sucker
and not with a bureaucratic barrier to
struggle over first
as a community and as individuals
trafford can offer at least that much to
these people and i truly hope that it
does
these ukrainian people are standing
in the way of a changed world order if
russia rides roughshod
and extinguishes the ukrainian spirit
europe's long established peaceful order
is over
russian bully boys will choose their
next annexation
so we must encourage the giving to the
ukrainians are very support possible
whilst not escalating the insanity of
the russian rulers
and we must support the search for a
prevailing world order
that encourages the russian people to
remove the regime that callously accepts
the slaughter of its neighbours
along with the bloody demise of its own
troops
mr mayor i never thought i would write a
speech like this
i never thought i would make a speech
like this
i never thought trafford children
would inherit a less safe work less safe
world
thank you
thank you councillor wetton and
councillor dagnol please
just like to say how very moved i am by
everybody who's spoken tonight
particularly by councillor wetton um and
thank you for your words tonight
um
as in all these
horrific situations there is always that
little [ __ ] of light and i just wanted
to take a moment to
recognize those trafford households who
are now preparing to welcome refugees
from the ukraine
into their homes it's such a laudable
action such a huge action to welcome
people into your home
to share your food your your you know
for children to share their toys with
other children and people you know are
starting to get in touch with us as
councillors and i just wanted to mention
them tonight you know
that they really do shine a light on a
really horrendous situation so thank you
to those households thank you for your
warmth and generosity and for making
your home their home i know everyone
here is moved and appalled by the
horrors happening in the ukraine
um
as a personal reference my granddad
arrived at baby arms from belarus
escaping from the russian pogroms
again he was sponsored
and welcomed into this country and he
survived
what we hope for these families and
children coming now is that they will be
welcomed
supported
that they will thrive
and that hopefully they will be able to
return home
um and i'm sure that we are all going to
do our absolute best to support our
residents who are
have extended that hand of friendship
and shown that little bit of humanity to
those people over there with nowhere to
go
so thank you to those people residents
of trafford we are here to help we want
to help and we will do everything that
we possibly can to make sure that those
refugees who end up here are welcome
supported thank you
thank you councillor dagnall councillor
butts please
thank you
russian hegemony over ukraine
an independent and law-abiding country
that has strived to become a strong
democratic independent nation living
under a shadow of a big bully now russia
the kremlin effectively
our moral material and hospital like
hospitality support to the ukrainian
people we hope will
maintain their high spirit swastika in
this period of darkness and uncertainty
we will see the ukrainian nation bounce
back
fitter and stronger and taken its place
amongst the democratic nations of the
world thank you sir
thank you councillor but
councillor hartley please
thank you mayor i wholeheartedly support
both of the motions and wholeheartedly
condemn the actions of of putin and the
russian government and uh i think as
council dagnan said i was very moved by
a lot of the speeches that we've we've
already heard and
um councilor morgan in in
in moving um the first motion
refer to the barbarity of the of the
russian regime in in very
graphic terms and i'd just like to add
to that and say that you know we have
seen
ukrainian civilians targeted we've seen
residential areas targeted by russian
forces children's hospitals
a theater
sheltering children and clearly labeled
as such from the air
and we've seen the brutality of
the armaments that the russian forces
have been using
information suggesting cluster bombs
have been used thermobaric bombs
and and now we understand the russian
government
rumored to be considering the use of
chemical weapons and
in the midst of all this horror of the
war that we see are innocent men women
and children
either pinned down in basements
sheltering from the bombs that fall day
and night unable to escape
or as others have said
forced to leave their homes with just
what they can carry
um i suppose a lot of people might say
what role do we as a council have to
play in all this you know this is this
is a really serious issue but what can
we do as a council well
i think both of the motions show what we
what we can do which is to
put on record where we stand and send a
clear message about where we stand
to uh to the russian government through
the through the russian ambassador and
to express our support for the ukrainian
people through the ukrainian ambassador
and to make clear to the prime minister
that all efforts should be made to
welcome refugees from ukraine uh to our
shores
if we and other councils send this
message then it does make a difference
and
as local councillors we are
representatives that are closest to the
people and
if we speak as one on this as a chamber
as i think we will and if we speak as
one on this with other councils i think
that sends a vital message
to the ukrainian people who are
suffering in ukraine but also to our
ukrainian community
and those of ukrainian heritage uh here
in trafford
i always think that
for anyone in this chamber we should
never seek to divide our communities and
i welcome what the members have said
about
not conflating the
uh the actions of the russian government
with the russian uh the russian people
and i think it behooves us all to be
careful and circumspect in our in our
language and our sentiments to make sure
that we don't do that
and finally we've we've heard a lot
about the efforts made in our local
community to help ukraine i know
trafford veterans i think have arranged
for uh 700 uh parcels of donations which
have all been delivered i think to st
matthews hall in stratford
and so there's you know there's
large-scale help there but i've been
really moved by
small-scale help speaking to residents
speaking to local businesses many of
them
have been moved to do whatever they can
setting up just giving pages
making donations of supplies that are
needed collecting those supplies and
delivering them to where
they are needed
finally i just want to say something
about
about refugees the
the horror of this war will be followed
by the horror of a movement of refugees
the likes of which we've not seen since
the second world war
already we've seen around three and a
half million refugees leave ukraine
mainly for neighbouring countries at the
moment
but there's also been over six million
ukrainians who've migrated within
ukraine you've had to pat their bag and
move predominantly east to west
obviously away from the fighting and
as the fighting goes on
as i think it will due to the resolve of
the ukrainian people more of those six
million people will then seek to leave
the borders of ukraine
and i believe we have a legal obligation
to provide safe haven to refugees
fleeing war
we certainly have a moral obligation and
we have a political responsibility as
well because our government and our
politicians and and many in the west and
in nato
have
turned a blind eye have have refused to
stand up to putin over many years
through
the brutality and the barbarity that
that he that he has sown and we're
paying the price for that now and we
definitely
take we need to take political
responsibility for
our part in in this crisis
but again i'd like to finish on a
positive as as councillor dagnall didn't
say that
the people of trafford that i've spoken
to are definitely ready they're ready to
offer their spare rooms to ukrainian
refugees
and i'm sure we're ready to welcome
ukrainian children to our classrooms
and we're ready to support ukrainians
through
the trauma which they will have ahead um
it will mainly be women and children
arriving here it
won't be many men but
many families you know will lose
fathers husbands sons brothers
in the in the war that's uh no doubt
ahead so i know it's not been easy for
the government it's not been easy for
the home office to quickly react to this
situation
this this war did have an air of
inevitability about it and
whilst it's not easy i do think that we
need to show our willingness to welcome
ukrainian refugees not just through our
words but through our deeds thank you
thank you councillor hartley councillor
blackburn please
thank you mayor
um i'm appalled and sickened by the
actions in ukraine of the russian troops
as directed by their evil and
megalomaniac leader putin the illegal
invasion and bombardment of their homes
businesses hospitals etc is inhuman and
criminal in a democratically elected and
independent country the millions who are
having to flee in terror with just a few
belongings in a suitcase leaving their
homes and some leaving family is
heartbreaking
during this cataclysmic onslaught i felt
this particularly personally because
just over a hundred years ago my family
was in the same position living in what
we now know as ukraine russian troops
were in their town going from house to
house emptying them with people and
ransacking homes of possessions my
granddad was attacked and had a gun held
to his head whilst my grandma was with
him with their three youngest boys aged
eight seven and three weeks old
my family fled my grandma took a few
photographs her samavar and the family
bible
not all their family or friends were so
lucky and they never saw them again
my granddad managed to get grandma to
safety and then went to fight just as
many men in ukraine ukraine are
currently doing now
experiences such as this deny future
good physical and mental health
the brave ukrainians who are separated
from each other not knowing whether they
will be reunited will have practically
nothing of their former lives the awful
trauma that they're undergoing is
unimaginable and are particularly fear
for the children young people who will
carry the terrifying memories with them
themselves forever i hope that the men
left fighting will eventually find their
families
and who knows who will return to the
ukraine i pray for those who are still
in the towns and cities being bombed and
existing in unspeakable conditions and i
hope they can escape to safety we can
only hope that the monster putin is
found guilty of the genocide and he pays
for his highness crimes thank you
thank you council blackburn any other
members wishing to speak
councillor welton
thank you mayor um
i'd like to uh
echo on behalf of the green group what
has been said this evening is deeply
moving
our heart speed for the people of
ukraine my family has signed up to be a
host and i
want to cry scrolling through the
descriptions of ordinary families adrift
from everything they know their future
is uncertain their loved ones in danger
we must do all that we can for them
and we
must extend the same hands of friendship
to all refugees no matter from where
they come
i have i
i have to depart from my script because
i have some
anger on my page here
about how we got to this situation which
i'm not going to go into
now i hope we'll have another
opportunity
to go into this in more depth
what can we do apart from express our
horror and sympathy take refugees
and support those sheltering elsewhere
in europe
the one thing i will say is we can also
hit putin putin where it hurts by
reducing our own reliance on the oil and
gas that binds us to the kremlin
and so many other unsavory regimes
around the world
the international energy agency has
given us a handy 10-point plan of how to
do it a lot of which we can do at count
council level i'm not going to go into
it now i hope members will
look it up
and consider
what we can do
there
because we won't just be stocking it to
putin we'll also be meeting so many of
our councils
other
parts of our agenda
as it turns out good local policy is
good energy policy
good energy policy is good foreign
policy and that's a lesson we certainly
need to learn here
thank you councillor welton councillor
newgross please
thank you
my words cannot do this subject justice
i i want to echo what has been so
eloquently expressed by the other
members of this chamber
i do believe we are going to join
together sending a unanimous message i
want to briefly thank the residents of
trafford who have already stepped
forward in numbers
um to help refugees
i know that the council is stepping
forward to look for how
however they can help and and i will
support that in every in every way
um so
i think
on that i shall leave it to the rest of
the council now to vote thank you thank
you councillor new crush councillor
weston please
thank you chair i will be brief because
we've heard um from many members
extremely eloquently
the position that is held across this
council chamber i would like to place on
record my thanks as others have to
the people of trafford who have as they
always do come together in a crisis and
are determined to stand with the people
of ukraine we have had many many
families come forward offering to host
and that is not
restricted to those who
have ukrainian relatives and friends who
they have offered sanctuary to i'm
talking about people who are welcoming
strangers into their own home because
that is what we do
in times of crisis i'd also like to
thank councillor evans and councillor
morgan um for altering the motion
because i think it has enabled us to
send a strong message tonight about the
unity that we have on this issue here in
trafford i will briefly mention the
important point again about rustophobia
because as priory ward councillors we
have been contacted um by members of the
russian community here in trafford
raising those concerns but we know and
it is important that we keep saying as
other members have this evening that
this is putin's war not the war of the
people of russia i won't um
indulge too much in foreign affairs from
my place here this evening
chair but i will just finish with a
quote from madeleine albright members
may have seen that news has broken in
the last couple of hours that she has
passed away
um but just a month ago
she said in a new york times
column ukraine is entitled to its
sovereignty no matter who its neighbours
happen to be
in the modern era great countries accept
that and so must mr putin
this is the message under girding recent
western diplomacy
it defines the difference
between a world governed by the rule of
law
and one answerable to no rules at all we
must ensure
that putin is
answerable and i am delighted with the
show of collective will in that
direction this evening thank you
thank you councillor weston councillor
morgan has the right to reply to his
motion councilor morgan
thank you thank you may um i'll keep it
brief um after a very good debate in
which what
given the motion it's a slight turn of
use of words um
someone once said about becoming a
parent and when these events happen that
it hits you and i never really
understood it until
recently
um and
i can't imagine what ukrainian parents
are having to say to their children at
the moment
whether that's cowering
in the night in the metro stations
recovering meager possessions from
what's left of a destroyed flat
or having to flee to another country one
that probably doesn't speak a language
that they understand
and
whilst we can't join their fight we need
to give them every support
along with welcoming as everyone as
others have said
welcoming those who choose to take
refuge from the horror in their country
here
as well as supporting those countries
which are nearer to ukraine like poland
and moldova are having to cope with a
huge huge number of people
the months may be difficult for ukraine
but the fundamental principle and to
agree with councillor western um
quote is that the future of of ukraine
should be with the people of ukraine and
the elected government of ukraine
tonight we need to we needed to show our
support for our ukrainian friends and i
think we have
thank you councillor morgan
and councillor dr carr you have the
right to reply to your motion
um i don't have anything further to say
except i just want to thank everyone all
our communities in trafford who are
working so hard to do anything that they
can whether it's big or small to to help
uh ukraine and all of the many refugees
thank you council dr carr and do i have
the council's consent to agree both
motions
thank you
motion 10c the next motion this evening
concerns procurement linked to human
rights abuses and is to be moved by
council london please council london
thank you chair
i won't say it's a fortune that we've
had the previous motion to discuss
tonight but i think it's certainly
allowed us to reflect
on
the importance that international events
which sometimes seem
quite a long way from these shores
can have on our own lives in due course
and i have been you know very touched by
the sentiments and feelings
and some of the actions that have been
described that know that members are
taking
individuals and their families in this
chamber and the residents across across
trafford
a number of members tonight have
mentioned the fact that
we've allowed putin to get away with it
to go too far
but i think
as often as the case
and hindsight is a wonderful thing
but to a large extent the writing has
been on the wall for a number of years
that's certainly been the case in the
country that i'm focusing the motion
tonight
and that's china in particular the
province of xinjiang
where
i hope i suspect most of the members
here and many residents across trafford
are fully aware of the the gross human
rights abuses that are taking place
to an ethnic minority
by
a sadistic brutal autocratic
communist party regime
as i've listed in the motion
the independent tribunal in london at
the end of last year after thorough
investigations taking witness
statements
examining the evidence supplied by
huge numbers of human uh united nations
agencies and human rights organizations
concluding in addition to the
torture rape
sexual violence
general persecution
whole hundreds of places of worship
literally bulldozed
similar numbers of cemeteries
for muslims bulldozed
simply because of the fear of
some in the the communist regime in
china that muslims in that part of the
world present some kind of existential
threat got to the stage where children
have been separated from their families
we've heard about some of that in
ukraine tonight
2000 was reported recently we're talking
tens of thousands
of uga children
separated now for years brought up in
re-education camps
these aren't the education camps these
are prisons
what kind of a re-education camp holds
you in that place for an indefinite
period
not knowing when you're going to go home
not knowing where your families are not
knowing where your children are who's
raising your children which homes are
your children not even knowing who is
actually in many cases actually occupied
your home to keep an eye on the
remaining members of the family
and yes xinjiang is
a thousand or so miles further east of
ukraine
but
the uggas are human beings just like you
and i
the ugis have families who are suffering
not in the immediate direct way
through weapons and bombs falling on
their homes but in a way that
many commentators and indeed united
nations representatives have described
as a slow genocide and indeed that's
what the
independent tribunal based its verdict
of genocide taking place
in xinjiang
based on
the systematic imposition of measures to
prevent births within the yuga
group the yuga communities
there will not be
in the future
a yuga community a hugo region
of the size of the population that has
been there in the recent past because of
these measures women of child bearing
age simply cannot now have the next
generation and that is the precise
policy of the communist party it's been
established by this independent
tribunal
this motion has been on the table
for a good 12 months or so
whether while the leader has kindly
discussed and negotiated with members of
the local government association about
how we could
include such emotion within local
councils not just here in trafford but
hopefully across england at the very
least
and you'll see the reference to
hopefully encouraging
fellow greater manchester councils to
uh look at supporting a similar motion
and similar actions with the graduate
procurement
we've talked about what actions we can
do
when we're talking about ukraine
to be quite honest with you
if this motion hadn't been
in the draft stages for some time
we could have quite easily widened it up
to include
broader issues of human rights abuses
where local councils like ours have huge
purchasing power where we can make a
difference yes it's not easy
yes we have to make sure that we're in
line with national legislation but we
have lobbying power we have strength in
this chamber and the chambers across the
country to put pressures on our national
government to make the changes to
national law so that we have the powers
within our local procurement bodies
to ensure that when we purchase products
and by god do we purchase products from
china these days not least in the
xinjiang
province from agricultural produce
produce to the latest technology
that nothing that we purchase that none
of taxpayers money is spent
anywhere near
organizations companies that are
involved with directly or indirectly in
slave labor we have the power to do that
and we have the will to do that not just
with the uga genocide but as the council
said the genocide that the president of
ukraine states is now taking place there
indeed many people agree with him and i
would be one of those
so perhaps let's use this motion as an
opportunity to think more broadly but i
urge you
for the time being
to accept this motion thank you chair
thank you council london
councillor weston
thank you
chair councillor london has
eloquently set out the reasons why this
motion matters and coming hot on the
heels of the motions debated previously
it feels very fitting
that we bring this here
today it is the case that there are
tremendous human rights abuses going on
um in the xinjiang province
against the uyghur muslims against
others
too and it is absolutely right that we
do everything that we can not just to
call that out but to intervene
to say that this is unacceptable and to
say that it must stop um i would just
say and i've discussed this with with
councillor evans um before
the before the meeting we have
circulated a proposed alteration to the
wording just to um
reflect
the need to ensure that we are acting
lawfully in um in the way that we go
about this which of course is um crucial
if we are to have impact
with this so i hope that the alteration
and i will move it formally chair um is
acceptable to the
to the chamber but you know we we simply
have to stop skirting around
these issues and not just as a as a
council not just as a country but as a
world
actually it is as councillor london said
slow genocide and we have a
responsibility to act so i am
formally seconding the motion chair but
also moving the alteration as circulated
thank you
thank you councillor weston
can i ask you council do council consent
to the imp to the
alteration
yeah
thank you any members wishing to speak
councillor evans
keep it brief
matt thank you
um our conservative group happy to be
pleased to support this motion and who
would ever want to support deal create
contracts with any state or organization
that engages in crimes against humanity
we certainly have a problem across the
western world
here in manchester we have embraced
regimes well china over the past 10 to
15 years with open arms i think it's now
recognized as a mistake as dealing with
putin and buying the oil has been
recognised as a mistake
and we need to extricate ourselves from
a situation probably of our own making
this will need care and consideration
but it is essential
we're all using tonight well and all
through the week lenovo laptops our live
stream is no doubt on equipment
manufactured by states who also commit
crimes against humanity we have a long
way to go but we almost take this
journey so we'll be supporting this
motion from there thank you thank you
thank you council evans councillor but
i'd like to come in
yes i think uh
uh
i support the uh
the motion that
has been put forward i mean anything to
raise awareness of the human rights
abuses that have been taking place i
mean it's unfortunate that muslim
nations across the middle east and asia
have not stood up for their brethren in
holding the prc to account at
international forums because of their
own precarious positions thank you
thank you councillor but anybody else
wish to come in councillor hassan
thank you
sorry it's my first speech
i fully
support
the motion being forwarded by my
colleague mr london uh
we discussed really a burning issue
today which has been passed and we are
united for ukraine issue
and mr logan has raised really a very
important issue which is ongoing across
the world and mr but my colleague has
just said about
middle east and another part of
asia so i fully
and strongly
uh sport this motion of my colleague mr
london thank you
thank you council hassan anybody else
council london you have the right to
reply
thank you chair um thank you for the
support uh supportive comments um
the final remark i'd like to make is uh
reflecting the remarks that we made with
regards to
russian residents of trafford greater
mansion the united kingdom we have many
residents in trafford in this part of
the world of chinese origin it would be
absolutely horrific if anybody as we
move forward
took our critique of the communist party
in china as a open season for any kind
of cyanophobia in this borough so i
think again we need to make sure that
we're not seem to and we certainly
aren't
condemning those kind of remarks thank
you
thank you council london
um
can we agree the motion
thank you everybody
motion 10d
counselor miss blackburn please can you
move the final motion concerning the
queen's platinum jubilee
um thank you
the motions this evening have
highlighted
awful things happening in the world
um and
i think
probably all of us are
feeling sort of quite low after things
of the speeches that have been made
and i'd like to propose this last motion
is set out
in the in the order papers
and i'm very pleased to bring this
motion to council in our own council
chamber
to ask that the chief executive of the
council takes steps to explore the
feasibility of renaming a road property
asset or landmark in trafford after
queen elizabeth is second to mark the
platinum jubilee
no doubt everyone here tonight and those
watching at home will be aware that this
year her majesty will become um
britain's first monarch to celebrate a
platinum jubilee after 70 years of
service
there will be a year-long platinum
jubilee celebrations throughout the
united kingdom the commonwealth and
around the world as communities come
together to celebrate the queen's
historic reign
as well as being our head of state the
queen acts as a focus for national
identity unity and pride gives a sense
of stability and continuity and supports
the ideal of voluntary service
the monarch has also been a patron to
over 600 charities and is the current
patron of various local and regional
organizations and institutions
such as lancashire county cricket club
uh manchester united infirmary and the
manchester geographical society
indeed the queen is no stranger to
trafford with her last visit being in
july last year when she visited the set
of coronation street including a walk
down the famous cobbles and a stop off
at the rover's return pub to help
celebrate the soap's diamond jubilee
to celebrate the monarch's unique
anniversary events and initiatives will
take place throughout the year
culminating in a four-day uk bank
holiday weekend from thursday the second
to sunday the fifth of june
the four days of celebrations will
include public events and community
activities as well as national moments
of reflection on the queen's 70 years of
remarkable service
in trafford we already know that several
community events are planned to mark
this momentous occasion
these include the carrington parish
queens jubilee beacon
and an exhibition at imperial war museum
north with collections and displays with
us with a special connection to the
queen's experience of war
um we know too that trafford council
will be marking the jubilee by lighting
up various um buildings in trafford
launching the queen's card competition
for children and young people
joining the queen's canopy by planting a
tree um in the world
gardens at flixton house and i'm just
losing the batteries
joining with st paul's church in sale
who will hold a church service to
recognize the work of the queen over the
past 70 years and we also know that
trafford libraries will be hosting
various activities for the queen's
jubilee
our conservative group is making an
additional request for a permanent
commemoration for the jubilee and i hope
that other groups can also support the
request as i say to name a road property
asset or landmark and to be named after
the queen it would be fitting in that in
future years trafford residents and
visitors to the borough have a permanent
reminder of the 70 plus years of
dedicated service that the queen has
given to the country thank you matt
thank you council blackburn um
councillor myers will second the motion
councilor myers
yes i'd like to second this motion and
uh
reserve the right thank you
thank you councillor myers anybody
wishing to speak
councillor holden please
thank you mr bear
it's with a certain degree of horror
that i've just realized that more than
half a century ago
i stood in an office
holding a bible in my left hand
and i swore to serve
and protect her majesty queen elizabeth
ii
in person crown and dignity
and god bless her she made that the
easiest promise i've ever made
i think the least we can do is find
something to name
this wonderful lady's
permanent name
for our history
thank you
thank you council holden councillor
welton please
thank you mayor
um
[Music]
we uh are happy to support this uh this
motion i just wanted to use it as an
opportunity as a member of the trafford
inclusive neighborhood grants panel to
say that there is an extra round of
uh funding um with the deadline of the
end of april um and uh we're hoping that
there will be um uh applications from
people you know who who want to have a
street party or a small part
a small event to celebrate either the
queen's jubilee or or coming out of
covid or or you know or just generally
community gatherings through the summer
and they have uh
pots of up to 500 pounds available for
events so please do um spread the word
amongst your
your local communities thank you very
much
thank you councillor welcome councillor
brotherton
thank you mr mayor
excuse me 70 years is certainly a
remarkable achievement and it's not
something that's likely to be matched in
many generations to come it's just
technically
impossible really so i i i certainly
would support this motion
i'm looking around i'm one of the few
people here probably who were actually
at school when the the coronation and we
all got then
oh
[Laughter]
well i didn't want to uh
drop other people in it but some of us
were at school at the time and i don't
know about coastal boys but we all
received a little spoon with a with a
sort of
crest on it
care of the uh courtesy of the cheshire
county council education committee and i
just wondered mr man oh there's a
costume involved in all these things but
if you're looking at feasibility of
things whether we could look at doing
something similar for primary school
children uh so they have a memento so
you know for you i think i have
somewhere i've probably got this little
spoon somewhere so they've got some
remember memento of this occasion and uh
more than just naming a road or a field
or something that we if we can
i know there's a cost if we can whether
we can give something to the primary
school kids to remind them as we all
well not all some of us got in 1953.
thank you chair
thank you councillor brotherton anybody
else wish to comment councillor wetton
just a very brief uh comment if i may
if we if we're going to do this if the
council's minded to support this
promotion
we've really got to do it properly and
we can't just choose some sort of side
street
or
i don't know a piece of rock somewhere
it's got to be something significant and
i haven't got a suggestion other than
one that's coming to my head is that we
renamed trafford park
in her honor with her name uh but it
needs to be i say that because it needs
to be something of that order of that
magnitude because we haven't got
so very much else in the way of roads or
or
we haven't got a mountain we haven't got
anything really that
that fits the task
so um
whoever's got got the job of choosing
this please make sure if it gets the
council support if that it really is a
significant gesture that we make
thank you councillor wetton councillor
butts please yeah just a quick one uh
from the history books tells us that the
there was a great art exhibition in
manchester in 1857 and the king
attended and actually passed through
altering him and a particular road which
is now which was named that time king's
way
was
renamed king's way because it actually
traveled through there so uh
just a
comment
thank you councillor but i think you're
saying it's been done before that's the
point you're making
councillor thomas
thank you chair i'll i'll be supporting
emotion as well having been
indoctrinated by my mother for 56 years
on this planet about the uh
the the greatness of the royalty and the
monarchy in this country and a bit of
it's myself
but again if we do propose this motion
and as we're saying
we have william rogue golf course which
is no longer a golf course as it goes
into fields in trust we hope uh going
forward perhaps we could name it queen
elizabeth ii urban park thank you chad
thank you councillor thomas
nobody else wishes to come in um
councillor blackburn you have the right
to reply
sorry apology
thank you chair i think you've um
probably caught the gist that we will be
supporting the motion i can't promise
any little spoons for barry
however
um
i i got the impression as he doesn't
know where it is it's probably not one
of his most treasured possessions
um so maybe we could improve
um big spoon or some other sort of um
cutlery perhaps but on the substantive
point we will of course uh support the
motion and ask the chief executive to
find something um of suitable stature
thank you jeff
thank you councillor blackburn you have
the right to reply thank you
thank you mayor um i don't know anybody
who is sort of over the age of 70 that
will have put
the country and the people of the
country before
her own
herself and and her family and
i know that everybody in this chamber is
not a monarchist but
looking at um what the queen has
achieved not just for
the people of britain but the the work
that she's done
in the commonwealth and in
you know
countries all over the world um and
personally i think she is you know a
wonderful person and and i very much
hope that trafford can
can
you know do ourselves proud um
in this respect thank you
thank you councillor blackburn
i think that motion is agreed by
everybody agreed
hi
thank you
um before we finish
we've got a number of councillors
retiring uh this time
um council london council long
councillor dylan council accordingly
thank you for that interruption council
london
council lamb councillor mitchell
councillor chilton and councillor kerry
can i thank all those councils for their
service
over the years it it makes the council
what it is
um
our councillors do work very very hard
and those councils have certainly worked
hard over the years i'm grateful to them
um and also it's somebody's last meeting
uh this evening and that's j and that's
jane leferve to my left
this is this is jane's last meeting i
think we've got um a gift for jane
and um i think jane lefer deserves a
round of applause for everybody
[Applause]
don't if you'd like to say a few words
jane
she's waiting 20 years for this
so
i can really now tell you what i all
what i think about you all
and i want to say first of all thank you
very very much it's
very unexpected and
quite overwhelming for me
and unaccustomed as i am to public
speaking i would like to say that
i miss you all terribly
i'd also like to say that it has been a
great
honor
to and a privilege to work with you all
these years
and i want to say a big thank you to you
not just for the flowers but for
everything that you do
everything that you do every day after
you've been elected i couldn't do what
you do
you know you put yourselves out there
you represent your communities you do
that
without any
you know want for thanks or anything and
i really respect that and we've heard
some great speeches here tonight
and it's
to me it sums up everything that is good
about
you and what you do
and
[Music]
i will miss working with you but i know
that you'll carry on in that great
tradition
that you are the cornerstone of our
british
democracy and and i really really take
my hat off to you and thank you so much
thank you jane that concludes the
meeting um if anybody would like to join
me for refreshment in the mayor's parlor
you're very welcome thank you
you